Salut , bienvenue au Vlog 130 du "Mental Vlog".
Vous savez pas ce que je pense , hein ?
Lui non plus ahahah
Soit il y a beaucoup de fumer soit il y a  une grosse cigarette électronique
Bonsoir (accent Québécois)
32, 32 ,32 , 32 .  Tu vas bien ? ça roule ?
Coucou
ahaha le coucou le moins viril du monde
ah ouais c'était un peu euhh voix d'enfant
Fabien: Les loges
Nico
Tu vas bien?
Nico: ça vloggg?
Fabien: Ouais grave
c'est cool
ça vlog de ouffffff
Bonjour ça va?
Salut! Booder
Je suis allé voir ta pièce y'a 3-4 jours
Vérino: salut,
J'allais d'abord faire la bise à ta caméra
Fabien: C'est vrai.
Vérino: ça va?
Bienvenue à l'inglorious
tu sais trop bien faire la bise à la caméra.
Fabien: Madame Vérino
Verin: Cesoir nous avons euh  Monsieur Jason Brokeers
Fabien: Attends je prends sa photo
V: Ouais nous avons Donel Jack'sman
F: Donel Jack'sman
V: Voilà nous avons... oui mais là pour le coup ... autant lui. Prends lui plutot.
F: Et oui.. Donel Jack'sman
V: Nous avons aussi Fabien Olicard évidemment
V: Nous avons Booder
Booder il es là, il est là
F: ah non y'a le vrai Booder en plus, il est où?
F: Elle est où ton affiche?
F: Elle est pas là ton affiche?
V: Voilà l'affiche de Booder
F: Elle est bien faite
B: Je suis l'affiche qui bouge
F: C'est l'affiche d'Harry Potter
B: ah c'est une grosse prod ahaha
V: Et nous avons Frederic Sigrist
F: Fred Sigrist
V: Fred Sigrist qui est là
Je me suis paumé dans les loges
je sais pas du tout par où passer...
ah mais non  c'est pas par là que je voulais aller. ahahah.
je me suis perdu
ouais ça me paraît mieux là
Le public s'installe
B:On n'as pas besoin d'eux en fait
F: On n'a pas besoin d'eux c'est dans la boîte ça.
B: De quoi?
B: Tu sais même pas de quoi je parle
F: mais c'est bien parce que je peux faire l'intro que je veux et à chaque fois je met ta voix derrière "on n'a pas besoin d'eux"
*applause*
V: Bravo. les gars.
Bonsoir à tous, bonsoir bienvenue
F: Y'a Esteban qui veut me poser des questions
moi j'ai dit ok je réponds à tes questions que si je peux te vloguer
alors moi aussi je vais te poser des questions
Esteban: Alors comment c'était?
F: C'était cool.C'était cool parce que le public de l'Inglorious est hyper bienveillant et hyper chaleureux. c'était vraiment très très bien.
F: Pourquoi tu as toujours une  casquette?
E:  Euh... pour tenir mes cheveux
F: Pour ten...
E: Oui oui pour tenir mes cheveux.
F: Fais voir... mais tu as rien en cheveux
E: Si si parce que sinon il tombe dans les yeux...
F: Oh p***** et c'est là qu'on se rencontre qu'en fait c'est Justin Bieber le mec
E: Ben oui c'est pour ça que je met une casquette pour dissimuler justement
F:  Parce qu'il est sur un plateau d'humoriste il sait qu'il va morfler si on voit ses cheveux tout le temps c'est sur.
cesoir j'ai fait un petit peu trop long sur scène je devais faire 12 min j' ai fait 17min
Mais j'ai trouvé mon maître ...
Oui dés qu'il s'agit de faire long.... c'est évidemment ... moi le maître en la matière.
F: Ahahah... Frederic Sigrist a fait 45min
Fred: Mais j'étais pas en forme
Les 2 : hahahaha
Fabien: Tu avais fait combien quand on avait fait l'Olympia?
Fred: ah non non j'étais dans les temps
Fabien:  Mais ils avaient coupé les lumières aussi
Fred: Mais j'étais dans les temps
Non c'était au grand point virgule où ça avait été très très long
Fabien: A pour les saluts
Fred: Oui tu sais pour les débuts de saison où on devais faire 7minutes et j'en ai fait 25
C'est surtout que je m'en rends pas compte
Et en fait tu vois j'avais mis dans ma poche en me disant ça va vibrer et ça n'a pas vibré
ahahah
Fabien:  je crois que je le connais depuis 2010
et depuis 2010 il me dit: "euh   je comprends pas mon portable ne vibre pas"
hahaha...
Fabien: je crois qu'il y a une fonction que t'as pas compris dans ton portable
Fabien: Voilà la tête de Vérino qui se dit "Pu*** 2 artistes 47min... pffff on est bon"
V: ahahah
Fred: Tu fais payer les heures supp aussi?
V:  non non sinon j'aurai arrêter depuis longtemps
Fred: C'est juste que tu as une vie que tu as envie de rentrer chez toi
V: hahaha
je comprends je comprends
V: Non j'ai envie de rentrer chez toi moi
Fabien: C'est beau ce que tu dis
Fred: Tu sais que je dors sur Paris là parce que c'est trop loin chez moi
V: Ben ouais ouais tu auras pas le dernier métro ^^ ahahah
Fred: Moi je prends le RER en plus
Fred: Et avec les travaux à 22h tu...
V: C'est vrai sans déconner... ah donc tu es coincé
Fabien: Il se passe de ces vannes en loges
V: Je suis 1er degré moi ahaha
Fabien: Ce qui est magnifique avec Vérino tu peux parler de tout il est intéressé
V: Ouais... c'est vrai?
Fred: C'est plus chaud là
V: Y'a un vrai problème
V: y'a la vision politique du fait qu'il a fait plus chaud.
Fred: Non mais c'est vrai
Fabien: Moi je l'avais prédis dans une enveloppe
Fred: l'agriculture intensive. ahaha forcément il y aura un problème de réchauffement
V:  Agriculture intensive... toi tu l'avais prédit dans ton enveloppe
On est bien
Fabien: Vous voyez qu'il est pas si méchant  que ça Dieudo quand même
Fred: ahahahah
V: je suis sur qu'il y'a la moitié de ton public qui sait pas ce qu'il veux voir haha
V: Non en vérité je vais vraiment être sincère avec vous c'est réellement ce que vous mettez dans le chapeau qui va payer les artistes qui sont là.
Les artistes je parle pas que des humoristes mais également toute l'équipe qui est derrière
Booder: Oui c'est vrai... il a raison.. Pardon
Excuse moi
B: On a des enfants nous
B: Excusez moi
V: non non mais reviens vite
V: Mais voilà c'est pour qu'il puisse payer un garde du corps pour son fils
Fabien: C'est la fin de l'Inglorious
On va faire la photo finale
on va faire le finish
On a déjà perdu la moitié des artistes Donel est rentré
V: On as déjà les images de là bas et maintenant là ^^
Merci
Booder: A la prochaine
Fabien: Tchou Mec Bravo c'était cool
Booder: Et il a deviné...
ce que j'allais deviner...
Un jour...
c'est...
Fabien: C'est Ouf ou pas?
B: C'est je sais pas comment... c'est le mentaliste
lui il est mentaliste mécanicien
Fabien: Et dans une enveloppe avant le spectacle j'avais un papier avec marqué 47min parce que je savais
Booder: qu'il allait faire 47min
Fabien: Exactement
Booder: C'est incroyable.Franchement moi je...
Excusez moi à quoi je pense là?
Fabien:  Euh... ah oui d'accord
Il veut que je fasse la promo pour la grande évasion dans sa tête.
Booder: Mais pu*** il est fort et... mais... et...
Fabien: Moi j'ai vu sa pièce la grande évasion à l'Apollo théatre allez le voir c'est vraiment mortel
Booder: Je crois que c'est un coup de chance
A quoi je pense là?
Fabien: Euh non pas ça...
Booder: oooohhh ah ah
Attends à quoi je pense comme çà?
Fabien: là tu penses à quoi tu pourrais penser
Booder: AAAAAAAAAhhhh
Booder: C'est un mentaliste ça veut dire il a du mental le mec
Prenez le pour l'équipe de France
Non mais sérieux on va faire un Euro de merde
Prenez le voilà c'est lui vous avez pas pris Benzema
Verino:  Et lui peux deviner que ça sera un Euro de merde
Booder: Il a deviné ce que j'ai deviné c'est incroyable
Moi je reste pas à côté de lui c'est un ouf
Fabien: Et lui il est en train de finir sa passage  regardez ahahah
*Rires*
Booder: Bonne soirée
Fabien: Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo
Vous avez vu je suis pas très bien réveillé
Parce qu'en fait il est... 6h du matin
il faut absolument que je monte la  vidéo avant un RDV important pour aujourd'hui
Si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas non plus à me le faire savoir
En laissant un petit pouce en l'air du lundi matin
qui fait du bien
Et euh... je sais plus ce que je voulais dire...
Oui en fin d'après midi ou  ce soir je mettrai une petite question sur facebook
par rapport à la vidéo de jeudi sur la fan page
de Facebook Fabien Olicard -
N'hésitez pas à y aller pour me donner votre sentiment
et voir ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse pour jeudi
Passez une très bonne semaine
et rdv demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog
Tchao